♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELL, GOOD
EVENING.
WELCOME TO A SPECIAL INSIDE
THE ISSUES EDITION OF "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
WE ARE TAKING A DEEPER DIVE
FOR THE NEXT HOUR BENEATH THE
HEADLINES IN SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT INFLUENCE THE WAY
AMERICA IS CHANGING.
FIRST TONIGHT WHEN ROBERT
MUELLER'S FINAL REPORT ON
RUSSIA CAME OUT THIS SPRING,
THE GENIUSES ON TELEVISION HAD
ONE WORD FOR IT.
"DAMNING."
TRULY AND COMPLETELY DAMNING.
SO DAMNING YOU COULD BLOCK THE
COLORADO RIVER WITH IT AND
CREATE YOUR OWN HYDROPOWER.
IT WAS THAT DAMNING.
WATCH.
>> THE REPORT HAS DAMNING WAYS
THAT THE PRESIDENT TRIED TO
INFLUENCE THE INVESTIGATION.
>> IT'S ARGUING THAT THE
MUELLER REPORT IS FAR MORE
DAMNING.
>> IT'S NOT PRETTY.
AN UGLY, DAMNING PIECE OF
BUSINESS.
>> I AGREE WITH HIM THAT IT'S
ABSOLUTELY DAMNING.
>> DEMOCRATS SAY THE REPORT IS
DAMNING.
>> THE REPORT, APART FROM THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL IS MORE
DAMNING THAN ALL THE REPORTS.
>> FAR MORE DAMNING TO THE
PRESIDENT THAN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL INITIALLY INDICATED.
>> BUT IT'S STILL VERY
DAMNING.
>> Tucker: AS WE TOLD YOU --
"DAMNING."
THAT IS WHAT THE GENIUSES
CONCLUDED BEFORE A SINGLE ONE
OF THEM READ THE REPORT.
IN FACT, THEY STILL HAVEN'T
READ IT.
BUT OTHER PEOPLE READ IT OR
SKIMMED IT AND THOSE PEOPLE
LET TELEVISION JOURNALISTS
KNOW IT DIDN'T SAY VERY MUCH.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
MUCH LESS TREASON.
NOT MUCH OF ANYTHING.
AT THAT POINT THEY HAD A
CHOICE TO MAKE.
THEY COULD HAVE MOVED ON AND
WORRY ABOUT AMERICA'S ACTUAL
PROBLEMS.
THERE ARE MANY OF THOSE.
OR DOUBLE DOWN ON A WEAK HAND
AND DEMAND ROBERT MUELLER
TESTIFY BEFORE CONGRESS.
THEY CHOSE THE LATTER.
MUELLER HIMSELF DIDN'T WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS.
HE DIDN'T SEE THE POINT OF IT
BUT DEMOCRATS INSISTED.
SO THIS WEDNESDAY MUELLER
SHUFFLED TO CAPITOL HILL, AND
THE DEMOCRATS PRODDED HIM LIKE
A ZOO ANIMAL TO HOPE HE WOULD
TRANSFORM TO CLARENCE DARRO
AND DENOUNCE TRUMP AS A
TRAITOR TO THE NATION AND A
WAR CRIMINAL.
BUT HE DIDN'T DO THAT.
SO CALIFORNIA'S TED LU PUSHED
HIM.
HE TRIED TO MAKE MUELLER
EXPLAIN HE DIDN'T INDICT TRUMP
BUT TRUMP SHOULD STILL BE IN
PRISON.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU
THAT THE REASON YOU DID NOT
INDICT DONALD TRUMP IS BECAUSE
OF THE OPINION YOU CANNOT
INDICT A SITTING PRESIDENT.
CORRECT?
>> THAT IS CORRECT.
>> Tucker: GET IT?
ORANGE MUSILINI WAS A CRIMINAL
ALL ALONG.
FINALLY, TED LU WAS ABLE TO
EXTRACT THE TRUTH FROM ROBERT
MUELLER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A CRIMINAL.
EXCEPT NOT.
A FEW HOURS LATER MUELLER
BACKTRACKED AND CLARIFIED HE
HAD NOT CALLED THE PRESIDENT A
CRIMINAL.
WATCH.
>> BEFORE WE GO TO QUESTIONS I
WANT TO ADD A CORRECTION TO MY
TESTIMONY THIS MORNING.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO ONE THING
THAT WAS SAID THIS MORNING BUT
MR. LU WHO SAID, "YOU DIDN'T
CHARGE THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE
OF THE O.L.C. OPINION."
THAT IS NOT THE CORRECT WAY TO
SAY IT.
AS WE SAID IN THE REPORT, WE
DID NOT REACH A DETERMINATION
WHETHER THE PRESIDENT
COMMITTED A CRIME.
>> Tucker: AS WE SAY IN THE
REPORT AND I SAID IN THE
OPENING, IN OTHER WORDS
MUELLER WASN'T SAYING ANYTHING
NEW.
HE WAS REPEATING WHAT HE HAD
BEEN SAYING FORLON.
CONGRESSMAN TED LIEU WAS NOT
CONVINCED AND INSTEAD HE
SMELLED A RAT.
THERE HAS TO BE A REASON THAT
MUELLER WAS UNWILLING TO
DISAVOW TWO YEARS OF WORK AND
HIS PRIOR STATEMENTS FOR A
TALKING POINT FOR TED LIEU.
WHAT COULD THE REASON BE?
HE HAD A GOOD IDEA.
CLEARLY, THE RUSSIANS HAD
GOTTEN TO MUELLER, TOO.
>> YOU WERE AT THE CENTER
YESTERDAY OF ONE OF THE MOST
DRAMATIC MOMENTS OF THE
HEARINGS WITH ROBERT MUELLER.
HE HAD TO WALK BACK HIS
TESTIMONY TO YOU IN RESPONSE
TO YOUR QUESTIONING.
>> IT WASN'T UNTIL THERE WAS A
RECESS, AND THE INTEL
COMMITTEE, HE STARTED TO WALK
IT BACK.
I DON'T KNOW WHO GOT TO HIM OR
WHO TALKED TO HIM BUT THAT WAS
VERY ODD WHAT HE DID.
>> WHAT ARE YOU SUGGESTING?
ARE YOU SAYING HE ONLY DID
THAT BECAUSE OF PRESSURE FROM
SOMEONE?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
BUT HE CLEARLY ANSWERED THE
WAY HE ANSWERED TO ME AND THEN
HE AT NUMEROUS TIMES -- HAD
NUMEROUS TIMES TO TO WALK IT
BACK.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> Tucker: HMM.
NOW TO BE CLEAR, THIS IS A
DIAGNOSIS, THIS IS HOW CRAZY
PEOPLE TALK.
TINFOIL TED IS A NUTCAKE.
LIKE YOUR COUSIN WHO CONVINCED
THE MOON LANDING WAS STAGED ON
A STAGE.
TED LIEU THINKS HE KNOWS
EVERYTHING.
HOW DID THEY GET TO MUELLER?
CRASH BRIBE WITH RUBLES?
BRAIN WAGING?
WAGE -- BRAINWASHING?
DID THEY GET TO HIS KIDS?
WE HOPE SOMEONE WILL ASK HIM
FOR DETAILS.
WE WOULD LIKE TO KNOW.
BUT FIRST IT MIGHT BE WORTH
CHECKING IN WITH HIS COLLEAGUE
SYLVESTER STALLONE
STLVESTER STALLONE
STALESTER STALLONE
STALLSTER STALLONE
STALL EER STALLONE
STALL ERI STALLONE
STALL ERICSTALLONE
STALL ERIC SALLONE
STALL ERIC SWALONE
STALL ERIC SWALWNE
STALL ERIC SWALWELL HAS GONE
AROUND THE
AROUND -HE
AROUND --E
AROUND -- ERIC SWALWELL, IF
YOU THINK LIEU HAS GONE AROUND
THE BEND.
WATCH THIS.
>> I FEAR WE ARE MORE
VULNERABLE THAN WE WERE IN
2016 BECAUSE RUSSIA AND THE
OTHER COUNTRIES WILL SEE THE
UNITED STATES AS OPEN FOR
BUSINESS WHEN IT COMES TO
INTERFERENCE.
>> DO YOU WORRY THAT THE
RUSSIANS DEVELOPED THE
CAPABILITY TO ACTUALLY CHANGE
VOTE COUNTS IN THE UNITED
STATES?
>> YES.
>> Tucker: YES.
AND TO THINK THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO BELIEVE WE SHOULD LEGALIZE
HALLUCINOGENIC MUSHROOMS.
A MIND IS A TERRIBLE THING TO
WASTE.
IT'S A SAD THING TO WATCH.
THEY HAVE TO EXIST IN TANGIBLE
REALITY.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY NO LONGER
DOES.
FOR TWO YEARS THEY READ ANYONE
WHO EVER READ A TOLSTOY
NOVEMBER OF BEING A RUSSIAN
AGENT.
THEY MEAN IT.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ TOLD
US RECENTLY THAT THE BORDER
ENFORCEMENT IS A PLOT TO BUILD
THE NAZI DEATH CASMS IN CAMPS AD
THE NAZI DEATH CASMS IN CAMPS AS
THE NAZI DEATH CASMS IN CAMPS AO
ON.